why was she in every interview with you
because I that's one thing my mom did
not do that that's one thing I didn't
ever see I mean why did she ever explain
to you why she would sit next to you in
interviews no it was just the way it
should be it was No One's Gonna Get You
I'm gonna I'm gonna be there I'm I'm
there first you're mine I'm not gonna
give you to somebody
and I'll protect you I'll answer the
guys of protection but it was more
ownership and fear I I think she was the
original
momager if you will and my mom became a
manager in honor of Terry Shields
because she was known in the industry as
the great protector of you the the one
who called the shots and yet I paid the
rent you paid the rent